بكلمات اخرى الحصول على مقاتلات افسته عشر
لم يعد حلما المستحيل بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
ومن الممكن ان يحصل بالفعل وترسلها واشنطن
لعده اسباب ما هي الاكياج تعول على مسانده
كبيره من الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اضافه
لدعم مسؤولين من الجمهوريين ايضا وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان وزراء دفاع
نيته سيناقشون تسليم الكياد مقاتلات في
اجتماعهم مقبل في المانيا في ما قال وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني اليكسي رزقي كاف في
مقابله مع قناه سي بي سي كنديه ان الوضع
العسكري في الشرق صعب لكنه تحت السيطره
بالكامل واوضح رزقك في المقابله التي
اجراها ان الامر سيستغرق بعض الوقت لتلقي
الدبابات التي وعد بها الغرب ولمعرفه
كيفيه استخدامها معربا عن عمله في ان تكون
جاهزه للاستخدام حلول شهر مارس